really day night like there wasn't a
moment where I didn't see his feelings
coming through the streets trying to get
to safety
[Music]
so we're driving deeper into BOSU eval
we're passing civilians holding white
flags along the way we're asking them
what they're running from and they're
saying that hi
Isis mortar bombs vehicle bombs have
been exploding around their
neighborhoods all day I saw a 12 year
old boy with traffic move in his chest I
[Music]
saw a woman who would be hit by a
shrapnel from mortar being pushed on a
hand cart there's something weird that
happens when you when you're going
through the war zone that it it just it
feels removed from your own life and I
just I always try to keep in mind that
these were regular people just like me
just like my family just like my friends
these were people who lived in a really
cosmopolitan diverse City and until 2
and a half years ago
I spoke to one family you know the
husband he told me he's like you know we
leave my wife for government employees
we live in a nice city and then all of a
sudden Isis came now here they are two
and a half years later and they've they
just got one suitcase of clothes and two
kids who looked shell-shocked this is
happening to people that I might
socialize with in my normal life that I
might that might be my friends that
might be my family if I if I were just
born in a country other than my own
[Music]
these are these are not this is not
something that's far away or that this
is not something they can't happen to
regular people assuming that only
happens to regular people
[Music]
you
[Music]